[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con con una
carta abierta dirigida a la canciller
alemana angela merkel
el experto en aerosoles christophe us
back pidió que se sensibilicen más a las
personas sobre el riesgo de contagio de
coronavirus que ocurre mayormente en
lugares cerrados y no al aire libre
asbaje es presidente de la sociedad para
la investigación de aerosoles y ha
criticado restricciones como el uso de
tapabocas en lugares abiertos señoras
bach bienvenido a france 24 en la carta
de abierta al gobierno alemán y en
particular a la canciller usted explica
que el peligro del virus acecha sobre
todo en lugares cerrados a qué se debe
este factor
siempre exhalamos partículas de aerosol
con nuestra respiración y en el caso de
una persona infectada éstas pueden
contener virus es decir esto distribuye
los virus en el aire y si no salgan
plaza al aire constante medios con
ventilación eficiente en lugares
cerrados se mantendrán los virus en el
aire y se añadirán nuevos es decir la
concentración de virus se acumula y esto
es exactamente lo que no puede ocurrir
en el exterior porque al aire libre
siempre tenemos una corriente de viento
que arrastra los virus de modo que la
concentración de virus también se diluye
constantemente
esto significa que al aire libre en el
peor de los casos puede inhalar unos
cuantos virus de alguien
aimar pero realmente siempre son
arrastrados lejos
en zonas cerradas la concentración de
virus aumenta continuamente y si estoy
allí con una persona infectada con el
tiempo inhaló más y más virus
de modo que en algún momento e inhalado
tantos virus que puede infectar me
teniendo en cuenta esta información que
deben hacer los gobiernos para combatir
ese peligro en espacios cerrados y
cualquier problema potencial en lugares
abiertos
y creo que es muy importante comunicar
siempre bien donde acechan los peligros
que acechan en el interior y casi nunca
en el exterior y por eso nosotros como
social para la investigación de
aerosoles digamos especialmente las
medidas que pretenden sugerir que podría
ser peligroso estar al aire libre
esto incluye en particular por ejemplo
la obligación de llevar tapabocas al
aire libre y así es un poco probable que
se den infecciones pero la obligación de
llevar tapabocas
armas así como la prohibición de
encontrarnos afuera con otras personas
sugieren que allí habría un peligro y en
su lugar puede haber reuniones en casas
en espacios cerrados también porque es
más difícil de controlar y ahí es donde
se produce realmente las infecciones
ustedes paperstorm por ello es
extremadamente importante comunicar
siempre con realidad dónde está el
peligro
es decir en el interior y casi nunca en
el exterior
el agua y que esto se refleje como
consecuencia en las medidas que se tomen
en el mundo
verne en reinos reflexiones
y qué pueden hacer las personas en sus
casas en sus trabajos o en el transporte
público para protegerse mejor
y hay que tener en cuenta varias cosas
de vista el punto más importante es
evitar los contactos especialmente en el
interior evitar los contactos significa
mantener el número de contacto lo más
bajo posible
pero también que el tiempo que pase con
otras personas en lugares cerrados sea
lo más corto posible
siempre que no sea posible evitar a la
gente en el interior debo recordar
ventilar lo mejor posible
su luz y una buena ventilación se
consigue abriendo totalmente la regular
es posible en varias habitaciones
paralelas al mismo tiempo y así me
aseguro de que haya un intercambio de y
eficiencia luz todos
además hay que tener en cuenta cada vez
que me encuentre con gente en lugares
cerrados más allá de los miembros del
propio lugar
debería llevar un tapabocas
especialmente con los demás porque
cuando se habla se producen muchas más
partículas de aerosol que pueden
contener virus y si una persona está
infectada
es decir cuando hablamos podemos
producir muchísimos más virus de lo que
uno quiero de protegerse adecuadamente
usando un tapabocas
señoras bajos muchas gracias por su
análisis por todas estas recomendaciones
a ustedes gracias por su sintonía por
acompañarnos continúen con nosotros aquí
en france 24 que hay más
[Música]